this week on brian ross investigates
parents passion the mothers and fathers
of school shooting victims demanding gun
reform a multi-million dollar settlement
for the makers of the ar-15 rifle used
to kill children at the sandy hook
school true justice
would be our 15 year old
healthy
and standing next to us right now
a father climbs a construction crane
across from the white house to send a
message to president biden about the
death of his son and others at the high
school in parkland florida
i was thinking
that joaquin needed me to get all the
way to the top of that thing and send a
message to the nation into the world
plus lessons from the great influenza
pandemic of 1918 how will it all end
this time
if we're truly not through this pandemic
and if another variant of concern pops
up and we have to roll back some of
these measures i'm not sure it's going
to be that easy to do so
and this week's winners and losers in
the media see if you agree with the
choices made by the editors of mediaite
the dnc emails were very clearly stolen
from within the building most likely by
a bernie sanders supporter
from the studios of the law and crime
trial
in new york city's herald square
this is brian ross investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our friends watching
on facebook live i'm brian ross joined
as always by my colleague rhonda
schwartz and rhonda we begin tonight
with a story of the passion of parents
whose children have been killed in one
of the all too many horrifying american
school shootings those moms and dads
have become a powerful force for safe
gun reform fighting stiff resistance at
every turn but now there's been a major
victory rhonda
brian gun manufacturer remington the
maker of the ar-15 style weapon has
agreed to a 73 million settle million
dollar settlement with the families of
nine young victims of the shooting at
sandy hook elementary school that killed
20 first graders and six adults
remington admitted no liability but it
is the largest payout by a gun
manufacturer in a mass shooting case and
the parents hope the case will be an
important step in punishing gun
manufacturers for the way they market
their weapons
david and i will never have true justice
true justice would be our 15 year old
healthy
and standing next to us right now
but benny will never be 15.
he will be six forever
because he is gone forever
nothing will bring dylan back
the closest i get to him now is by
kissing his urn every night
telling him i love him and i miss him
but i made him a promise and i'll keep
working to deliver that promise for the
rest of my life
my hope for this lawsuit is that by
facing and finally being penalized for
the impact of their work
gun companies along with the insurance
and banking industries that enable them
will be forced to make their practices
safer than they've ever been
which will save lives and stop more
shootings
at the white house president biden
called it a historic settlement echoing
what the president said last december on
the ninth anniversary of the deadly
sandy hook shootings
as a nation
we owe all these families more than our
prayers
we owe them action
the settlement came on the fourth
anniversary of the deadly shooting at
another school the high school in
parkland florida
some of the parents of the children
killed in that shooting were protesting
in washington over a lack of action
one father manny oliver actually climbed
a huge construction crane across the
street from the white house to protest
unfurling an image of his late son
joaquin oliveira climbed a 150 foot
construction crane not too far from the
white house hoping to bring awareness to
gun control across the country manuel
oliver who lost his son in the math
school shooting in parkland florida
delivered a message to the president i
got for
oliver was released from jail shortly
after and went back to the white house
continuing to demonstrate he says being
arrested is nothing compared to losing
his son
and we're joined now by manny oliver mr
oliver thank you so much for joining us
uh tell me what you were thinking as you
climbed up that crane across the street
from the white house
i was thinking um that joaquin needed me
to
get all the way to the top of that thing
and and send a message to the nation and
to the world um
that message was not only for the
president it was for a whole society to
understand uh how bad these gun violence
issue has become
it's been now more than four years since
you lost your son
you feel you cannot get heard by the
president by president biden who
promised to do all sorts of things to
reform and increase gun safety when we
spoke my wife patricia myself when we
spoke to president biden
and during his campaign he was very
serious about this issue and we took it
as a serious issue for him we had a
connection
uh an emotional connection by both of us
uh
went through the loss of a son
of a loved one so i really believe in
his words and um
but right now it's more about results
uh i'm not only blaming biden itself
this is a
inaction that it's beyond the white
house
but the president of the united states
is joe biden so i think is is who
deserves to receive the message first
and if you were to meet with him what
would you say to president biden
a few things but i will ask him to
prioritize this issue um
with a statement that is really powerful
and legit
uh not with promises and and false
expectations
um
i think that a leader like biden could
easily handle
this issue just by being a little more
aggressive and he has a great
opportunity at the state of the union
that's on a general
way way i'm being more specific i i
already asked his advisors to
to name a national director um for gun
violence like a national office of
gun violence that's easy for him to do
it will mean a lot to us and it will
require no voting or no
agreements between politicians it's just
his call
as you know republicans in congress have
blocked every effort to
impose some sort of gun safety reforms
what do you say about this whole
situation in washington that they are
hearing you and other parents who have
lost their children
well shame on them
they were elected by people so they
should protect people um they should be
concerned about this
uh they've heard us and i have no doubt
that they've heard us uh basically
because we keep on doing things like
what we did yesterday
and it's and it's beyond republicans at
this point
it's becoming more ethical than
political
you saw the parents uh from the sandy
hook have now received a settlement from
remington the maker of the ar-15 is that
a path that you may want to go down
i think it's important i think it marks
a precedent i think it holds accountable
the gun industry for the first time ever
and i'm hoping that this is the first of
many um
i'm happy for for those families uh
by winning this battle
what we went through is prices
no amount of money will compensate or
lost but in terms of um
moving forward as a society and be more
um
i don't know a little more justice
bringing a little more justice to the
whole
uh going issue problem i think is a good
first step you were arrested after you
came down from the crane uh how does it
stand with you legally and are you
planning to do more actions like that
um
yes i am planning to do way more than
that
this is a process i learn every day
how to react
if something is not working or i feel
that it's not strong enough i will move
on to another campaign to another action
i would love to
start having more people doing the same
thing this is uh
uh
good trouble
right
good cause
so um
and yes i will go through some
consequences uh legal consequences but i
have my lawyer and i have all the
support that i need so it's a minor
consequence if you compare these to what
other people are suffering every day
they lose a loved one
you and so many parents have been
through so much you must think of your
son every day even though it's been four
years since you lost him
every minute you know what i i've
learned from my son a lot since the last
four years
my son was
very well educated and
smart guy he had everything athletic he
was he was a role model
and and he left many messages like
literally messages like posting tweeting
on social media so
we went over all that information that
usually a dad won't do because you just
respect those limits right but joaquin
left us a book
of instructions
and and we follow those instructions
what we do is an extension of what
joaquin will be doing he requires us to
do it because you need physical presence
to do those which is also why
we we make sure that everything is is
protecting our safety i mean what i did
yesterday was under very
safety measures because i need to be
here i cannot allow myself not being
here or risking my life uh otherwise
joaquin wouldn't have his dad to do the
things that i do
and you feel if joaquin was still here
he'd be taking the same sorts of actions
again would it be on a higher crane
absolutely all right manny oliver i want
to thank you so much for being with us
here tonight
thank you very much
coming up next what we can learn from
the end of the killer flu pandemic of
1918. you're watching brian ross
investigates on the lawn crime trial
network
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate lawn crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
across big parts of the country the
cases of kova 19 are dropping sharply
and the masks are about to come off as a
number of governors are preparing to
lift masked mandates in their states so
what does history teach us about how the
pandemic might end or whether it's too
soon to return to normal
and we're joined now by professor alex
navarro from the university of michigan
center for the history of medicine and
alex thank you so much for being here we
see the mass coming off in this country
what are the lessons from 1918 as to how
the influenza epidemic then ended
so i think the big lesson from 1918 that
we can draw
is that while we don't know where the
covid pandemic is headed we hopefully we
hope that it that it's going to end soon
the lesson from 1918 is that when health
departments started to remove those
social distancing orders
and masking orders in 1918
some cities had to reimplement them they
were not through with their pandemic and
it became very difficult if not
impossible to do so so the concern that
i have today if history is any lesson is
that as we see states removing their
masking orders if we're truly not
through this pandemic and if another
variant of concern pops up and we have
to roll back some of these measures i'm
not sure it's going to be that easy to
do so
how did it end in 1918 just suddenly
went away
no not at all in fact you know pandemics
they all end up but they don't just end
overnight uh you know you'll have a slow
diminution of cases or rapid as we're
seeing today uh and it will eventually
reach some sort of baseline uh and that
will likely be seasonal with a
respiratory disease such as such as
covid
in 1918 was there the great resistance
to mass there was no vaccine then
there was by and large now we i can't
say for sure how many people i can't put
a percentage on how many people comply
versus how many people didn't what we do
know is that by and large most people
seem to comply with most of the social
distancing orders the closure orders etc
the one thing that really got people
angry in 1918 were in those communities
that implemented mass mandates a number
of communities did especially out west
denver seattle san francisco oakland etc
and in those communities we have ample
evidence that there were many people who
did not wear their masks and there were
lots of others who had their masks with
them and maybe thought they could get
away without wearing it
and were caught by police officers and
in most of those cases they were
arrested and fined
in san francisco
there was there were two masked mandates
when the epidemic was not over and there
was another surge they implemented
another round of mass mandates but no
closure orders and that second round of
mass mandates really angered a lot of
people so much so that an anti-mass
league was formed and about 2 000 people
met uh to complain about the masks and
to listen to
uh lectures by some physicians in the
area you said they didn't work
politicians who said it was an
infringement on the civil liberties all
of the same types of things that we're
hearing today
and what similarities do you see between
then and now in terms of this resistance
to mass mandates and of course now the
vaccine mandates what does that come out
of
well i think there's a deep-seated um
you know sort of social understanding in
america that we we hold our our personal
freedoms our individual freedoms very
dearly um and of course people did in
1918 as well and so there's a there's
resistance to you know the notion of the
government telling you or forcing
someone to do something that they don't
want and that's understandable i think
the big difference though uh between
1918 and today is that that resistance
in 1918
was by and large not political it may
have been ideological but it wasn't
partisan there were people who were both
republicans and democrats in terms of
both politicians as well as you know
voters
who either agreed or disagreed with the
mass mandates and it the party lines
weren't drawn nearly as heavily as today
we have no evidence that this was a part
and there was any partisan opposition in
1918 unlike today where it really
heavily does uh follow along party lines
indeed it does so based on what you've
seen in the history what do you expect
to happen now in this country going
forward
well that's the million-dollar question
you know uh we're talking about the end
of the pandemic i think it's probably a
little bit premature to talk about the
end of the pandemic we talk about what
will society look like after we don't
really know if 1918 is any sort of guide
the fact is that when the restrictions
were removed and when public health
officers and other officials essentially
signaled that the epidemic was over
people by and large went back to their
lives as normal and pretty quickly now
certainly those who lost family and and
friends they grieved but that grieving
was done largely in private there were
no
large memorials or commemorations of
any of the big milestones and people
were by and large more concerned with
the war and of course the war ends on
november 11 1918 and and that's really i
think what drives you know popular
culture and the response after in that
1919 into the early 1920 period
is really the response to the end of the
war and not so much a response to the
end of the pandemic people just
essentially rushed headlong into what
life was like pre-pandemic going out to
movies going dining going bowling etc
and finally comparing the death tolls
between them and now
so this is a little bit tricky so you
know we don't have an official death
toll for the 1918 pandemic historians
estimate around 675 000 americans had
died um
we're obviously well above that i think
we're at 910 000 americans dead from
covid so uh in terms of broad numbers
covet is deadlier but in terms of the
case fatality rate
influenza 1918 was deadlier there were
far fewer americans about a third the
nation was about a third the size it is
today in terms of population so more
people who got sick from influenza died
in 1918 than uh in terms of covid but of
course that largely has to do with the
fact that we have better medical
therapies we have you know ventilators
medical oxygen and obviously vaccines
today
all right professor alex navarro from
the university of michigan center for
the history of medicine thank you so
much for being with us here today
you're welcome
up next this week's winners and losers
in the media see if you agree with what
the editors of mediaite had to say about
tucker carlson and fox you're watching
brian ross investigates on the law and
crime trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of mediaite and we're joined by
ade mclaughlin who's the editor-in-chief
of mediaite which like the law and crime
trial network is part of the dan abrams
media group and aidan you've chosen as
your winner this week the new york times
for a front page blockbuster story five
bylines
more details on the travails at cnn
that's right uh it is a five-by-line
piece a giant expose that was just
dropped um about how jeff zucker who was
uh the chief of cnn uh until earlier
this month
came to fall uh you know he ran the
network since 2013
um his downfall uh was followed shortly
after uh chris cuomo's downfall who was
the nine pm anchor on the network and
this year times expose gives a lot of
new details about this one crucial piece
of reporting that it adds is that it
gives a little bit more details as to a
certain sexual harassment allegation
against chris cuomo during his time at
abc that we didn't know about until now
we knew that it existed because cnn
alluded to it in a statement when they
fired chris cuomo towards the end of the
end of last year but the times really
gave some some new details on it and
another bit of reporting that chris
cuomo this the the his accuser alleges
that he reached out to her
and ended up airing a flattering uh
segment on cnn about her new company
during the metoo movement now she
believes according to this new york
times report that that was an effort to
silence her
if so that would be a huge violation of
journalistic standards a massive ethical
issue for cnn on top of a sexual
harassment allegation against chris
cuomo a bombshell report that continues
to shake cnn for this week's loser
tucker carlson at fox look what he had
to say about the latest conspiracy
theory in old one that he's beating the
horse about again
vladimir putin did not hack the dnc
there was never any evidence that the
russians hacked the dnc instead the dnc
emails were very clearly stolen from
within the building most likely by a
bernie sanders supporter who wanted to
show the world how bernie sanders was
being shafted by the very same corrupt
forces in washington that later shafted
donald trump aiden hasn't that theory
been totally debunked even by fox
uh that is right brian so that theory
that uh tucker carlson is alluding to
there is the seth rich conspiracy theory
which holds that a young 27 year old dnc
staffer uh was the uh source of the uh
clinton's emails which were sent to the
wikileaks and eventually published uh
now we know that seth rich was not the
source of those leaks he was killed
that's what started the conspiracy
theory as murder remains unsolved but
police say that there's nothing
suspicious about it there's nothing
linking him uh to wikileaks uh what we
do know from robert mueller's uh
investigation uh which contradicts what
tucker said on there there is that
russia was behind those leaks to
wikileaks uh in fact uh robert miller
indicted uh 12 russians as having been
involved in that hack um so what tucker
is saying on air there is just
completely invented and took and fox
news actually got sued a couple years
ago by the rich family for pushing that
conspiracy theory and settled with the
rich family reportedly for millions of
dollars so the fact that that conspiracy
theory is being again promoted on air is
really troubling so fox settled and he
raises it again
again a couple years later now fox did
not settle because of comments that were
made by carlson at the time it was sean
hannity who was actually pushing that
theory um but uh fox news retracted all
its reporting and settled with the
family so it's just bizarre that he's
bringing it up again well once again
some strange stuff from tucker carlson
aide mclaughlin thank you so much for
being with us tonight for your continued
great reporting on what's happening in
the media
thanks brian and thanks to all of you
for joining us tonight that is our
program tonight thanks for being here
we'll be back again next week
[Music]
you